[Music]
Here We Go Again Sony have announced the
games we will get as PS plus essential
subscribers for the month of June 2023
the following games will be downloadable
from Tuesday the 6th of June please
leave a like if this video is useful and
remember I don't pick the games I only
tell you about them so here we go June
kicks off with Jurassic world Evolution
2 a construction and management
simulator based around the movie
franchise of the same name it's your job
to manage the business and spend money
to grow the pack while bringing in
enough money to keep the lights on with
more than 75 prehistoric species of Dino
to find homes for the concentration
needed to make this a success can't be
undersold dedication is needed to build
enclosures select the right diets for
your dinos and quick thinking is
required when suddenly a T-Rex escapes
and starts hunting down your herbivores
oh and you've got to manage the people
too because an unhappy worker has the
potential to sabotage your Park
especially if you ignore their pay rise
requests this place is also a theme park
so build rides for your visitors and
keep the approval rating skyrocketing
Jurassic world Evolution 2 has a review
score of just shy of 7 out of 10. my
recommendation this June is Trek to yomi
a side-scrolling atmospheric Samurai
fighter but don't expect to be spamming
buttons through this five-hour journey
trektiyomi is all about watching the
postures of your enemies and reacting
the right way to take them out quickly
and effectively with blocks parries and
counters admittedly there isn't much
depth after that except a few shuriken
throws and other projectile weapons like
a crossbow the real focus of trick to
yomi is the short but compelling story
that attempts to bring the beauty of old
Samurai movies to the Video Game World
after surviving an attack which wiped
out his hometown we must pick up our
Katana and claim revenge and soon this
realistic story takes a turn into The
Surreal I won't spoil it but I quite
enjoyed it reviewers say Trek to yomi is
a 7 out of 10 game I think it's worth
your time next we have a sports game and
NBA 2k23 if you don't like sports games
or if you're in a country that couldn't
care less about basketball I'm sure this
sucks for you but let's look on the
bright side with an impressive visual
upgrade from last year's game 2k23 has
an up-to-date roster in both the NBA and
women's NBA and with new animations this
game looks more like the basketball on
TV than ever before the biggest downfall
of 2k23 was the Despicable micro
transactions that pushed players to open
their wallet to compete and progress in
the career mode there's a pretty cool
open world segment to this game where
there's a city to explore whilst on a
skateboard giving you something to do
when you're not on the court with a
basketball in hand there's quite a few
on-caught game modes to play through
like the Jordan Challenge which serves
as a timeline of the great man's career
and there's other eras too that look at
Magic Johnson and Larry Bird reviews are
mixed but I've combined them all
together and the average score is 7.5
out of 10. so that's our month what are
you thinking please sound off in the
comments below are you happy sad
frustrated glad let me know I'm Adam
you're awesome it's been a pleasure see
ya
[Music]